any guy we texted he definitely thinks
that I'm something else what's the
strangest thing that you've ever done to
get a guy's attention strangest thing
love letters no that's strange
I mean I've definitely like I was into
this one guy who was like kind of like
punk and cool and rock and roll so I
like went out and like bought like black
high-top converse and like literally
like planned out my outfits for I knew
he would be around but I looked at like
cool and alternative as possible
major crush time we ended up dating
oh yeah exactly
what about you what's the strange thing
you've done I haven't really gone so far
with with weird I haven't I was so shy I
was way too nervous to talk to guys
that's so surprising especially with
your character but you're so sweet so I
guess the big theme of this film and
it's about breaking down society's
standards of beauty I know as women
we've been body shamed how do you guys
combat that how do you handle that on a
day-to-day basis somehow I just have to
kind of try and separate yourself from
that pressure I mean even though it's
constantly in your face the entire time
you just if you're surrounded by good
friends who will constantly remind you
you don't have to be a certain way you
know I mean and I love like I'm very
interested in like makeup and fashion
and beauty I love that but I think it's
such a subjective thing the idea that
there's like this societal standard for
what is beautiful and what it's not as
ridiculous it really is I've found
beauty in such unexpected places so I
think the most beautiful thing that you
can do is like you know to be yourself
and to you know own it yeah are there
any celebs who are like your body
confident inspiration because I know I
have mine who I'm like oh oh mine's
Beyonce
I mean literally the Queen I mean
there's just so many people who are just
embracing who they are they shook keys
oh she doesn't like wear makeup very
often and she's just like she just has
radiates like confidence it's so cool
this is Stewart this does feel like
thing yeah yeah I want to talk about
Ciara
oh my gosh she was my absolute favorite
little sunflower were there any elements
to pull from your own life into the
character yeah definitely I mean I
definitely relate to like I mean not
being only part of the popular crowd but
like she wasn't a loser you know in the
end like I think she was pretty self
confident and like had like a best
friend and was doing all right in high
school before like this boy showed up
and changed everything
and I kind of know how that feels to to
like have your world turned upside down
you know so it's it's good it was cool
to like pull from that looking at you
makes me want to gouge my eyes out how
do you hope fans fall in love with each
of your characters or learn from your
characters there's so much you can
relate to everyone's journey is so
different and unique and I hope that
they all find like it strengthens to
just be themselves yeah absolutely I
think that's like the real message that
it's so much more important to like find
your own Worth and value than to like
strive for some unattainable ideal like
just be yourself
right we don't need perfection just
excellence right ladies yeah absolutely
you are a magnificent Beast
[Music]
[Applause]